all righty guys it is time for drew's
news your daily slalom down the good
news slopes
pizza french fry and with me at the desk
is my little snow bunny rossi ross
matthews
[Applause]
and then they
oh they jump it out they're like
remember suzy chapstick anybody
suzie chapstick no god who was susie
chopstick she was this like blonde skier
and she was amazing and she would wear
like pantyhose leg warmers and then like
do the splits and mid-air suzy chapstick
wow that was that was her real name suzy
chapstick sounds like a drag queen i
know i have to say that name
is a little you know what you're right
right i sound very drag race
all right well first up um we're not the
first to do this but we're not going to
miss out on the party of congratulating
rihanna and asap
rocky tonight reports they're expecting
their first child and they were seen out
in new york this weekend baby bump out
and they snapped this dreamy pick right
here in harlem the place where asap
rocky grew up how come rihanna look so
good when hello i mean when i come home
from a happy hour after having like
three nuggets i don't look that good
this woman is pregnant creating another
human and look how gorge
i know but it's so rihanna it's so hard
to do this
i i just i'm so happy for her too she's
such a good person and her
i i'm just i was thrilled to see this
and the fact that it was like in his
home and there's a picture where he's
just kissing her head and
it just made me so happy i know there's
they're so cute and you know i will say
the fans online though have been waiting
like when is when is she going to drop
an album when is it going to happen it's
about nine more months i think you might
have to wait she's gonna drop a baby
first and then maybe a new one dropping
something for sure and um
this story i grabbed on to a few i don't
know about last week i said we have to
do a story on the news about wordle
uh-huh uh who here knows word all oh
please raise your hands
i'm obsessed it was like that thing
where you didn't know it the day before
and the next day it's it's just invading
your life everywhere and uh you know the
huge uh news from the new york times
just hit they have purchased the runaway
hit game for a low seven figures
interestingly enough wordle was designed
by a a man named josh wardle and it was
a gift for his girlfriend because she
loved playing word games he lives in
brooklyn he put it together for her but
i gotta say i was surprised by a low
seven figures i thought this was gonna
be the next big several hundred million
dollar sale well i think it could have
been you know if they candy crushed it
out and i know shade the candy crush i
love you too but this is like playing an
atari game it is very simple the
graphics are simple but it's all i think
that adds to what is so alluring about
it i play it every single morning and i
text uh wellington um and it started
when we would play we'd be like oh look
babe good for you you got it in three
tries you got it in two and now is like
death match we are so competitive about
who's doing better on wordle but you
know i think everyone's gonna be
obsessed with this eventually but you're
right if he could have there's a i
pictured it like being like a mega
million dollar
me too enterprise now do you want me to
start texting you how i do onward yeah
let's do it you want it yes yes yeah i
love that it's also not an app it's just
a link it's also lo-fi maybe that's what
we're loving about it and that's what i
mean by like atari it feels like this
game could have existed in like 1983.
yeah yeah i i am so into it so um well
yeah so that's the news on wordle all
right well
i love this story the white house has
delivered on an important promise to the
nation they finally got a cat look and i
love this i'll kitty
npr reports america's first cat is named
willow apparently she and first lady
jill biden met on the campaign trail
this is a true story jill was giving a
speech at a farm and willow just jumped
up on that stage and she knew she was
home uh she's named after the first
lady's hometown of willow grove
pennsylvania i love that the cat chose
jill biden you know when when you find
your animal if you go to the shelter or
something you look into their eyes and
you're like you're mine i know you and i
think they know it too i rescued a cat
named kitty in las vegas she was in an
alley
and um she needed a home and then my
best friend robin ended up taking her
and she lived a very
very long life i thought kitty was lucky
you know hooking up with us yeah this
cat
very smart choice very smart i once
rescued a stripper named kitty in las
vegas
oh hi kitty all right uh next up
she's a big fan we've got a recap from
last weekend's big fight in sports
sports
uh bbc reports it was cutthroat cushion
combat at the pfcs this weekend and if
you're wondering what that is it is the
pillow fighting championships this is a
real thing look at them go
these pros pummeled each other with
pillows
[Applause]
and big congrats to the men's champ
holly tillman and the women's champ
estella nunez uh okay now drew this may
be one sport that i could actually excel
in you know because
i am known to be very handy with the
decorative throw pillow i can like throw
down
um and we actually happen to have um
pillows right here
[Applause]
um can i just throw out there that their
uniforms should be onesie pajamas with a
little grid like grippies on the bottom
i just want to say
but are you ready to oh she's taking her
earrings off uh oh
i was all down now i'm kind of scared of
you barrymore
you ready to go i'm gonna let me fluff
my pillow hold on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]